hey girl
remember those ryan gosling memes guys
we got ourselves a trailer for a movie
that since the day was announced i have
been heavily anticipating it's also
reportedly netflix's most expensive like
biggest budgeted movie ever it stars my
obsession ryan gosling seriously my
obsession hasn't been in a movie in
years chris evans anna de armas directed
by the russo brothers it's called the
gray man i'm genuinely really really
really looking forward to this movie
even if this trailer ends up being awful
i'm going to
still watch this movie we're going to
react to this movie put it up here on
the channel the day it comes out leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated
also subscribe and click that
notification bell we got a lot coming
out this weekend especially let's get to
it guys
[Music]
what do you know about the sierra
program
reckless mystery man you guys send in
when you can officially send anyone else
the great man
that's what a great menace
i got an urgent locate and destroy
that could be fun the man's got some
street cred
[Music]
i'm so excited
you hurt
i mean my ego's a little bruised
they have something they really want
what's your gut it's going to be my
funeral you're going to next billy bob
you got to kill some people
oh that must be lloyd what gave it away
the trash dash it's just it leans
[Music]
i'm about to put a hit so big on your
boy's head
that even his most loyal allies don't
hesitate to drop a dime
oh oh i'm here
i'll be vying for the prestige of
killing the infamous year six
i can kill anybody
maybe not anybody
[Music]
oh man oh man select the eaters too i'm
just so looking forward to that i'm so
looking forward to that i mean it looks
like a pretty you know generic action
spidey that's me
it does don't get me wrong i'm not that
that is something that trailer doesn't
seem to be shying away from whatsoever
but it just looks like such an
entertaining time i am incredibly biased
i got to be upfront with you guys i am
just so biased i was already sold on
this movie just from knowing that chris
evans and ryan gosling are going to be
in a movie together i'm excited for ryan
gosling because you know he hasn't
really had that many a hasn't done a
movie in quite some time and b drive is
one of my all-time favorite movies but
that's like art house action and i think
like the the last more direct action
movie was a film i did not really like
which was gangster squad and
this
is like russo brothers captain america
winter soldier civil war type of action
style and this is more of like a direct
just action thriller that's a big part
of it but dude i'm sure
chris evans you got to be loving when
he's doing here oh absolutely yeah you
know the further away i think he gets
from captain america the more sort of no
holds barred and fun he gets to be and
have yeah i mean this kind of movie
seems like it's much more about the
casting and much more about watching the
different actors you know bring some fun
and some uh you know
big presence to these roles and i think
chris evans absolutely is a great way to
balance that out because it's a little
against type to see him play so maniacal
even though in
recent roles he's been going more in
that direction so it's fun to see him
take the gloves off and then for ryan
gosling you know it's nice to see that
he's done various movies that are kind
of approaching this but never one that's
like in this vein of mainstream huge
production value starring role action to
have them both facing off against each
other is really exciting in that manner
and uh and two i mean anna de armas has
been just like she is this [ __ ] owning
[ __ ]
all genres all profiles reunited with
chris and reunite with chris evans from
knives out yeah like this definitely
seems like the kind of thing that i'm
sure will shine through the russo's
direction and whatnot because yeah i
mean they have some visual personality
it's not as much on display in a trailer
like this i feel like especially you
look at like the winter soldier action
and stuff like that it plays a lot
better when you're watching the scene
and you can feed on the chaos you got
glimpses though yeah yeah yeah i mean
this isn't as much about dazzling shots
it's not as john wick as like the
initial pitch had made me think but i i
think this will be a very you know high
scale and very thrilling action i think
it'll be a little bit more comedic too
that oh the trailer's probably letting
on like you get some of the sarcastic
wit from ryan gosling's character you
get some of that maniacal glee from
chris evans character i think it'll
probably have a little bit more actual
direct fun yeah than what this trailer
is leading on which kind of makes it
look a little like two thousand action
thriller yeah
yeah and i think that's part of two they
wanna probably play on our perceptions
especially of ryan gosling like i feel
like we know he's funny we know he can
you know put on the charm and that kind
of you know charming lead action
character but i think that's kind of a
smart thing to not give away too much of
in the trailer because again i think a
movie like this is heavily driven by its
cast and the personalities they bring
well i'm hoping the trailer is more is
really holding back a lot more the russo
brothers have talked about how they do
have sequels in mind that they have like
their own cinematic universe in mind for
what they would want to do here because
right now the the world doesn't feel
entirely unique you know that's the part
of it that feels like like we keep
saying like generic action through like
this is one of those movies that there's
very few movies nowadays that i will
watch strictly due to the cast and the
filmmakers involved that combo of just
them just gets me that excited
so i feel like i'm not just saying this
to be kind just but everything i've read
up on and i'll be honest with the movie
comes out if it ends up being crap i'll
say it you know if i ever i think it's
possible there's been a single thing
i've seen ryan gosling and that i
haven't liked him even though movies i
didn't like i was like right
and so i i feel like worst case that'll
be the situation that the performances
will at least be really entertaining and
the action will be cool i do want to get
more of a taste of like what makes this
espionage thriller world unique to
justify building like a universe out
yeah and granted i remember even you
know like uh you know something like
john wick or even drive those are two
really beloved films that were their
first trailers did not really capture
what made those films special you know
john wick looked like a generic action
movie and then people were like this is
so different and amazing and same thing
with drive people thought it was going
to be like some stupid
action movie yeah like there's not at
all with the trailers what did it look
like to be and i'm hoping that we walk
away with a bit of a dif of that vibe
because i know they did cherry the russo
brothers but i'm also hoping that it
goes back some of that real like
grittiness
and and like pulse pounding type of
espionage through the way winter soldier
specifically was as it stands i'm really
looking forward to it i took this
trailer very seriously
no jokes in this video today wear it on
your sleeves man because yeah i'm pumped
for this but guys what did you think
about it leave your thoughts down below
please subscribe click that bell keep a
lookout for everything we got coming up
this weekend last but not least setting
with a
we gotta shout out the newest patron of
the month ryan cross
project you get the traditional shout
out but just with your first name r
stands for righteous
y stands for
yowza a stands for awesome n stands for
don't say it don't say that word i'm
sorry say that word
can't get away with saying that word
especially nowadays
it's been decades you haven't been able
to say that word and you especially
can't say that why i would have thought
he was a different n word she's a
different sorry brother um how's about
ooh now that's a spicy meatball
ryan's a spicy sexy guy much better and
man maybe even italian who knows
cross project
[Music]